What choices did you pick David?
>> So there's a few different ways we
can do the mapping between the sun,
the planet on the left and the nucleus
and the electron on the right.
If we look only at the top half of each
representation all we can really say
is that the sun must map to one of them
and the planet must map to one of them.
Because these relationships
are symmetrical,
if I don't consider the bottom half
it wouldn't matter which is which.
If I look at the bottom half of
the representations however,
it tells me which part of the Solar
System must correspond to which part of
the Atomic Structure.
The planet revolves around the Sun, and
the electron revolves
around the nucleus.
So the planet and
the electron must correspond because
both are doing the revolving and the Sun
and the nucleus must correspond because
they are the centers of the revolution.
So, the sun corresponds
to the nucleus and
the planet corresponds to the electron.
>> This is right, David.
Another thing to take away from here is,
look at the depth of understanding it
requires in order to be able to make
the right kind of correspondences.
If one did not have the right kind
of model for the solar system and
atomic structure that captures
the deep relationships,
then the mapping may not be done and
the alignment wouldn't work.
And we would not be able to
understand the atomic structure
in terms of the solar system.
This models deep and rich models of
the two systems, the target problem and
the source case are essential to
deciding how to align them, how to map
them, and as we will see in a moment,
what to transfer and how to transfer it.